[Music]
on this Wednesday night dangerous winter
weather the miserable mess in the
maritimes and a polar vortex plunging
the Prairies into a deep freeze and I
just love this S Plus the next weather
system Sweeping in Ecuador descends into
gang violence it's really quite
astonishing and where some nut Trend
what ignited it and the constant fear
among
residents
global national with Donna freezen good
evening and thanks for joining us there
are warnings about storms and Bone
chilling temperatures in nearly every
Province and territory tonight from
heavy snow and rain slamming the
maritimes to a deep freeze on the
Prairies there's no question winter is
here and it is packing a
punch high tide coincided with strong
winds in St Andrews New Brunswick
creating a huge storm surge thousands
across the marit times lost power
schools across Pei in New Brunswick were
closed as a storm delivered a mix of
snow rain and wind further west on the
Prairies and parts of Central and
northern BC it is dangerously cold the
wind chill could make it feel like minus
40 or 50 into the
weekend we have it all covered with
reporters in Calgary Toronto and Halifax
and that's where Heidi pachuk starts us
off
tonight this WARF in the New Brunswick
Village of Grand Manan took a beating as
the system hit the maritimes we
certainly saw water breaking over other
Warf structures here on the island a lot
of water in people's backyards you know
coming out close to the roadways waves
pounding the coast in other places too
but all the Wind and Rain wasn't even
the
start most affected by this system began
their day by clearing snow with
widespread school closures throughout
the maritimes folks in frederickton and
Beyond digging out Winters missed us for
quite a period of time so we're due
heavy Wind and Rain knocked out power
for as many as 7700 electricity
customers in Nova Scotia we saw winds in
the 85 to 95 kilometer an hour range and
in some cases that did cause trees to
come down into our power lines in the
Halifax area it's localized flooding
that is the biggest concern rather than
shoveling snow because this system is
bringing plenty of rain and high wind
gusts water pooling on Halifax streets
and turning an outdoor skating rink into
more of a swimming
pool the wintry blast hit Ontario and
Quebec first dumping heavy snow it's
January it's January and I like seeing
white delaying flights in Ottawa and
creating hazardous driving conditions
particularly early this morning some
very uh uh High cases of drainage issues
so water ponding along roadways
by the time it hit Quebec a significant
snowfall kept plows busy which along
with strong winds closed schools and cut
power to thousands one of our workers
reported that there was a carport that
was like blown off by the wind and
landed in the line so that's the kind of
things that workers in the field are
dealing with right now as the storm now
blows on East Newland is next once this
one is done there's another on the way
this weekend Heidi pic Global News news
Halifax on the Prairies a polar vortex
has settled in in some areas this week
it could be colder than it's been in
decades and people are figuring out how
to deal with it here's Heather yorx
West it's a uniquely Canadian labor of
love volunteers braving the elements to
get the neighborhood ice rink ready for
the kids actually other than the thumbs
were really good so far dressed warmly
and whatnot so it's good after a mild
start to the season the Prairies are now
firmly in Winter's grip thanks to the
polar vortex it's very cold from someone
who's traveling from Australia I've
never experienced anything below minus
10 the icy weather a matter of life and
death for the unhoused we all have the
luxury of getting into vehicles that are
warm or going to a warm home uh
unfortunately the this part of the
community doesn't get to do that but
there were tense moments in Edmonton
when police moved in to dismantle an
encampment temperatures hovered around
20 below things only get colder as the
week goes on by Friday many areas of the
Prairies are looking at daytime highs of
minus 30 made even more frigid with the
wind chill areas like Calgary haven't
seen daytime Highs at minus 30 for a
couple of decades since the early 2000s
so it is rare for areas as far as South
is Calgary even if you look towards
Regina and over in parts of the interior
of BC the the northern prairies could
see windchill making it feel like -50
when it's that cold frostbite can happen
very
quickly Vehicles can disappear very
quickly
too as part of an awareness campaign
Wednesday Lethbridge police found 45
Vehicles idling unlocked and unattended
the cold weather giving would be Thieves
plenty of opportunity for their
crimes still it is January in Canada and
the most seasoned Prairie residents are
taking the cold and stride I just love
the snow I love my Winters I love my
Manitoba Heather urix West Global News
Calgary so what are we in for Global
News meteorologist Anthony Farnell is
with me Anthony there are more winter
weather systems on their
way that's right Donna it's kind of
daunting when you think of a storm
taking a very similar track with the
same or even stronger intensity as this
one that's still impacting parts of
Atlantic Canada with those tremendous
winds very heavy rain and for New
Finland and Labrador lots of snow
locally 30 or more cenm so once this low
moves out we're already watching the
next one and the one after that it's
called the parade of Storms and you can
see it here this is a clipper that's
going to bring light snow on Thursday to
Southern Ontario but this is the one in
the west that we are tracking closely
because it also has some extremely cold
air on the North flank and that
encompasses all of the Prairies and soon
BC as well this is air from Siberia that
has come over the pole and Friday could
be one of the coldest days we've seen in
quite some time with high temperatures
staying below -30 locally in Alberta
with wind chills approaching minus 50 so
it's cold out west and that cold is
eventually heading east but not before
another St strong storm with a very
similar impact across the eastern half
of Canada behind it Lake Effects snow
and that's going to be a concern right
into the middle of next week Donna blame
it on Siberia Anthony thanks in British
Colombia Avalanche Canada is warning of
a considerable Avalanche risk for most
of that province's back country
forecasters say the recent heavy
snowfall means the snow is not yet
settled 14 people died in avalanches in
BC last year in California one person is
dead after an avalanche at Palisades
Tahoe ski resort the slide happened this
morning about 30 minutes after the
resort opened it involved steep slopes
in an area used by expert skiers and
snowboarders police say another person
sustained minor injuries search efforts
have now concluded the resort was home
to the 1960 Winter Games property taxes
are going up in many Canadian cities but
people in Toronto were bracing for what
could be the biggest increase ever
property taxes could jump 10.5% in 2024
to cover a $1.8 billion shortfall in
this year's budget due to Chronic
underfunding of city services and there
could be an additional 6% increase if
the federal government doesn't provide
funding for refugees and Asylum seekers
in Toronto's shelter system I did not
create this financial mess but it needs
to be fixed we need to get the city back
on
track there are proposed property tax
spikes in cities across the country more
than 7% in Vancouver and Calgary nearly
5% in Montreal most of Canada's other
major cities have kept it to a single
digit increase Canada's Health Minister
says the federal government will do
everything in its power to ensure the
National Drug Supply does not face any
shortages after Florida was approved to
import cheaper Canadian
pharmaceuticals there is no way we will
allow any jurisdiction uh be it a state
or U another foreign jurisdiction to
endanger uh the Canadian drug Supply
last week the US Food and Drug
Administration authorized Florida to
import certain Pharmaceuticals in bulk
from Canadian wholesalers Health
Minister Mark Holland says the proposal
is inappropriate adding the US
politicians should not be looking to
Canada to solve their drug pricing
problems he says he will be raising the
issue with us officials during an
upcoming visit to Washington officials
in Ecuador say at least 10 people have
been killed in a wave of violence that
has brought the South American Nation to
a standstill heav armed soldiers roam
the streets of Ecuador's big biggest
cities today which were largely deserted
a day after the president Daniel naboa
declared his country was at War the
opponent is nearly two dozen gangs that
have taken over some of the nation's
largest prisons and are said to be
holding more than 130 people hostage
Mike dray on the escalating violence in
what was once a peaceful
Haven with every car bomb in gunfight
with
police the drug gangs fighting for
control of Ecuador's underworld grow
Bolder in broad daylight cars are lit on
fire despite a heavy police and military
presence leaving regular citizens
terrified they'll get caught in the
crossfire we live in constant fear says
this man because we don't know if we'll
come home from work in one
piece the current crisis devolved after
Adolfo fto masas A drug lord who was
immortalized in this Narco worship video
escaped from prison on
Sunday after president Daniel NOOA
declared a state of emergency on Monday
in hopes of recapturing fito all hell
broke
loose which led to Armed gang members
taking brief control of a TV station
during a live broadcast this is one of
the most dramatic shifts uh in South
American politics in recent years a
sudden increase in political and
criminal violence in uh in Ecuador it's
really quite astonishing and where some
new trend Ecuador explains UBC political
science Professor Max Cameron fell
victim to political corruption over the
past decade which opened the door for
the drug cartels to gain control of the
prisons and the ports when President
noboa came to power in November he
pledged to restore peace today he says
Ecuador is now at War and I think that's
right I think this is what um we might
call it kind of a critical juncture this
is a moment in Ecuador's history where
the kinds of decisions that are possible
and the kinds of decisions that are made
are going to shape the future of that
country for quite a long time to come
for now the streets in the capital Kito
remain chaotic as ecuadorians come to
grips with the violence that has
engulfed the country Mike Dr Global News
Toronto a diplomatic Mission coming up
what the US Secretary of State is trying
to achieve in the Middle
East the World Health Organization says
it continues to face what it calls near
insurmountable challenges getting
humanitarian Aid into Gaza it's had to
cancel seven Aid missions since December
26th including one today because it
didn't get permission from Israel the
organization says Aid requests were
refused and safe passage was not
guaranteed it says it has supplies teams
and plans in place what it doesn't have
is access and it's calling on Israel to
approve requests Israel denies its
creating bottlenecks saying its
increased capacity to inspect Aid and
reopen the border crossing last month as
Israel's Siege on Gaza goes on an
Israeli delegation is in Cairo for new
talks on the release of Israeli hostages
held by Hamas and the US Secretary of
State continues his diplomacy efforts
telling Israeli leaders countries like
Saudi Arabia are willing to normalize
relations with Israel after the the war
ends but only if there is a path to a
future Palestinian state right now as
Crystal ganing Reports there is no path
to
peace sorrow with no end in
sight the Palestinian red crescent
society says an Israeli air strike hit
one of its ambulances in central Gaza
killing four staff
members a direct Target means we won't
be able to save the lives of the
Wounded Israel's closest Ally the United
States had just urged them to do more to
protect civilian lives in Gaza IDF
officials have said they are moving to a
targeted phase of the war one that would
be less intense but the day brought more
death and
despair 14 Houses full of children and
women full of men and newborns too who
should we complain to our goal is to rid
Gaza of Hamas terrorists and free our
hostages once this is achieved Gaza can
be demilitarized and deradicalized
thereby creating a possibility for a
better future for Israel and
Palestinians alike the United States is
looking to the Palestinian Authority as
a possible leader in Gaza after the war
but it failed there previously leaving
Gaza open for
Hamas Lincoln's visit led to
demonstrations in the streets of romala
some got into shoving matches with
security teams they oppose blinkin being
in the Palestinian territory because of
America's support for Israel and its War
a claim that Israel is committing
genocide will go before the
international court of justice starting
Thursday the case was brought forward by
South Africa such a ruling could take
years but an immediate order could be
issued calling for Israel to Halt its
operations even if that happens it's
unlikely to bring about an end to the
fighting in Gaza Donna crystal ganing in
London tonight thanks Crystal us and
British Naval forces say they've shot
down 21 drones and missiles over the Red
Sea launched by Yemen's hooty Rebels
Britain says yesterday's attack was the
largest yet on Red Sea shipping there
were no reported injuries or damage but
the US claims it was the 26th Time
commercial shipping lanes have been
targeted since November 19th the houthis
are promising to step up pressure in the
area until Israel stops The Siege on
Gaza the US says many of the houi
attacks are targeting vessels with no
ties to Israel and that they are
unlawful and
escalatory Hunter Biden surprised
Republicans today when he unexpectedly
arrived at a US House Committee hearing
that was Voting to hold him in contempt
of congress
Biden sat quietly in the front row as
the oversight committee delivered
opening statements the committee voted
in favor of formally recommending the
household Hunter Biden in contempt of
congress for defying a subpoena and the
Republican impeachment inquiry into his
father Biden was subpoena to testify
behind closed doors last month as part
of the inquiry he refused to comply
insisting he will only testify in
public still ahead why Rebel news is
threatening to sue the
[Music]
RCMP the RCMP says it's looking into the
arrest of a commentator for Rebel news
David menes was taken into custody after
trying to ask Deputy Prime Minister
Christia Freeland a question outside an
event in Ontario on Monday M Freeland
how come the irdc is not a terrorist
group why is your government supporting
is
L what are
you you you're under arrest for assault
this video posted by Rebel news shows
men's attempting to ask Freeland
questions on the sidewalk and then told
he is being arrested for assault for
pushing into the RCMP officer menzes was
later released without charge the RCMP
is facing questions about what some are
calling a heavy-handed response Rebel
news calls it a false arrest and is
threatening legal action against the
RCMP Alaska Airlines is preemptively
cancelling all flights on Boeing 737 Max
9 planes until Saturday the
seattle-based airline says 110 to 150
flights a day will be grounded while it
awaits new instructions from Boeing and
federal officials on how to inspect the
fleet last Friday a door plug blew out
of an Alaska Airlines plane mid-flight
the only other carrier in the US or
Canada that operates the max 9 is United
Airlines lines and it is also cancelling
flights and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Donna FZ tonight's
your Canada is this double rainbow in
kitum British Columbia a little bit of
brightness and a light we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to viewers
global.com and thanks for watching hope
to see you here again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye